tim weiner chronicles the history of the
central intelligence agency in his book
legacy of ashes the history of the cia
mr weiner's research included the use of
over 50 000 documents and interviews
with 10 directors of central
intelligence
he analyzes the inherent difficulties in
maintaining classified information in an
open democracy and argues that the cia
has consistently struggled in the field
of espionage tim weiner discusses his
book with washington post columnist
david ignatius
[Music]
tim weiner it's a pleasure to to be here
with you and your new book legacy of
ashes which has just been published it's
an extraordinary study
of the cia as i've been covering the cia
off and on for over 30 years and i don't
know that a book like this has ever
really been attempted a comprehensive
systematic history of the agency maybe
you could start our conversation by
talking a little bit about how you came
to to undertake a book of this scope and
how long it took you to do it well i've
been covering cia off and on i've done
other things
since 1987.
and it started out
in kind of a marvelous way i
wanted to go to afghanistan
to see what american foreign policy
during the soviet occupation of
afghanistan looked like
from that end
the barrel of the gun
the united states was shipping hundreds
of millions of dollars a year to
the islamic resistance of afghanistan
the people of afghanistan
who were fighting a brutal
soviet occupation
before i went
i called cia
and said i understand you people do
country briefings sometimes for
reporters who are going to exotic places
may i have one
bill casey had recently died
and bill casey didn't do those he had
cut them off
so they said no
have a nice trip
well i did have a nice trip it was a
marvelous trip a long trip
and when i came back from afghanistan i
hadn't been back in washington more than
36 hours before the phone rang
and was ci saying hey tim how'd you like
to come in for that interview now
that was a two-way street that
discussion so that was my first time
entering the headquarters of cia
and sitting down face to face with cia
officers
and as you know reporters and spies are
not
completely different from one another
many real similarities between the two
lines of work that's something that is
clear to you and me as reporters and i
think is probably clear to a lot of
intelligence professionals
one rule we should just say for
people watching the show is that is that
you know this really is as similar as
they are these are oil and water they
don't mix they shouldn't mix
um it's really important for reporters
especially people like you who cover the
agency to keep a distance right so talk
talk about talk about i mean this is
this is a great big book um and and just
you know it's sort of like thinking i'm
gonna climb mount everest uh how did you
decide that you were gonna gonna sit
down and write a history you hope the
history of the cia
it wasn't that long ago
less than three years ago
when i began to feel that the amount of
available documentation on cia had
reached a critical
mass my last book about ci was all on
the record and i wanted this book to be
all on the record no anonymous sources
no blind quotes
if i quoted somebody i wanted the person
speaking or i wanted to be able to cite
something he or she had written
an old editor of mine
gene roberts once said great stories
don't break they ooze
and enough
declassified documentation had at that
point come out and i had been
writing about cia reporting on cia
thinking about cia for almost two
decades i thought i can do this now
there's enough
material that
i can put my hands on to write on the
record history
i should say as a reader who follows
this subject i was astonished by
just how much has been declassified you
were quoting from documents that have
been rumored to exist but not only
existed but are now declassified and
available to you did you have any fights
with the agency in trying to get stuff
available so you could use it or maybe
fights is the wrong word any
negotiations to try to pull stuff out so
that it would be available now the last
really great
history book about cia was done um 12
years ago by evan thomas
and evan did negotiate with cia and did
get
a rather painfully
executed
agreement
uh whereby he could read some of the
clandestine histories
no i think it's a tribute to the
transparency of american democracy that
you could even write a book like this
a great deal has come out
not
necessarily through cia the state
department
over the last
four or five years
has put out an enormous amount
of primary documentation on
american foreign policy this is what
we're talking about when we're talking
about cia
the cia
executes american foreign policy
they are
have been since the early 60s since the
bay of pigs
acutely
responsive to presidential command and
control
and
arguments about the cia tend to be
arguments about american foreign policy
during the cold war the left criticized
the cia for what it did
ever since the right has criticized the
cia for what it can't do
this
is a part of the american government
cia we're americans this is an open
democratic society
and the story of this book
is how we have struggled for 60 years to
run a secret intelligence service in an
open american democracy
the um
we'll talk about the details of this
story uh
in a bit but but i wish you'd
say a little bit more about about the
broad themes because you know there's a
way in which
this book will be read should be read as
an indictment
of the cia of its performance over a
very long period
of its inadequacy as
our
spy service and just
summarize for folks if you would
what your conclusions are at the end of
all this research you've done it is not
unpatriotic to say we have to get better
at this
mission the mission of cia is to know
the enemy that is very difficult
but that is what it is called upon to do
and in order to know your enemy you have
to talk
to your enemy and you have to spy
on your enemy
we have magnificent technology
to stare down from space
and eavesdrop on electronic
communications telecommunications
but the only way
to know another man's mind is to talk to
him and this is the business of spies
you can't talk to the enemy you can't
spy on the enemy if you don't speak his
language
if you don't know his culture
we as americans
are not good at this because we are an
open democracy
this is not an indictment of cia the
mission i believe
is crucial
to the united states
but when i say diamond i mean i mean the
performance of the cast of characters
who've conducted this business for uh
well let me let me let me ask you to to
to sum up then
what
um
what judgment would you give um you know
looking back at this at this 60-year
story
i will quote richard helms on this
richard helms was the director of
central intelligence for seven years
under presidents johnson and nixon and
before that
a career cia officer
one of the founding fathers of cia and
before that with the oss during world
war ii
and richard helms said
not one president
with the possible exception of george
bush the elder who after all ran the
agency
for about a year
not one president understood the first
thing about the secret operations of the
cia
and in large part this is a story of
presidents who have misused and abused
the cia because they don't understand it
a theme that runs through the book which
was fascinating to me
was the recurring tension between
the ci's information collecting
intelligence gathering role and its
covert action role covert action
for viewers
is a reference to
a kind of secret activity that really is
meant to change
other countries political systems we
have paramilitary covert action we said
in secret armies we have political
covert action programs where we'll seek
to bribe the politicians of another
country this is the part of the cia's
mission that seeks to overthrow
governments that we don't like
and through your book this this tension
between the two wings between very
colorful personalities on each side
comes up again and again maybe you just
would talk people through that theme
in the book
when harry truman created the cia 60
years ago what he wanted was a newspaper
he wanted information consolidated from
all sources
available to the government of the
united states and delivered to him each
morning
so he wouldn't have to read a two-foot
stack of cables
very quickly
the cold war
got very very tense
the soviets had been our allies during
world war ii
without them hitler would not have been
defeated
these two nations began to clash
before the war was over
joseph stalin was an implacable evil
leader harry truman was probably the
opposite
we set out to know the world through the
cia
but the emergency of the cold war
and the emergency of the korean war
impelled us to try and change the world
think of it as a spectrum
here are the intelligence analysts they
mostly work at headquarters
they live in the suburbs of virginia and
maryland
here and that is
analysis
well who's going to get the information
for them
the spies
that's espionage
they are overseas
stealing secrets
suborning people in many cases paying
for the information buying it from
foreign intelligence services
and sending it back to headquarters
to figure out what it all means
and over here
our paramilitary folks
are people who try and steal elections
swing elections and that is war by other
means
and that is the gen that is the spectrum
of what the cia does
what we're not we're pretty good at
analysis
the cia got vietnam less wrong i think
than any other branch of the government
and we're really good at blowing things
up
the best
what we're not good at is espionage
and why why do you think that that's
that's so is um you can make an argument
that
espionage reading other people's mail
artfully
[Music]
submorting people to to commit treason
against their countries which is what
spying is all about after all
is un-american it just doesn't fit well
with our national character is that
how much of it is do you think is that
simple problem
i think that's the heart of it
we as americans
play by a set of rules
that is the opposite
of what espionage is
you know
we
don't have a deep history
of treachery and betrayal
and
screwing your enemies
we like to fight fair and square
the russians
had been at this for quite some
centuries the british had been at it for
quite some centuries
and they knew the black arts
better than we did
there's another aspect to this
which i think is crucial
you cannot command control or contain
a foreign country with people serving to
your rotations
when the british ran an empire they
lived
in the countries
that they aimed to contain and control
i know a woman
who was born in india in the 1930s the
seventh generation of her family
born in india in the british foreign
service and in the british intelligence
service
you can't do that on two-year rotations
if
we as a nation aim to be a superpower
and we do
we are going to project our power
overseas
to do that you need to see over the
horizon
that's the job of spies and when
intelligence fails
you get war you get korea you get
vietnam and you get iraq and soldiers
die
well we'll get to iraq which is the
kind of
tragic conclusion that's looming as you
turn the pages of your book but to go
back to the beginning
there's an argument that the cia's
problems
originated in the fact that it was
created
almost cloned from the british
intelligence service
sis secret intelligence service or mi6
that that while bill donovan the founder
of oss
was so much under british influence
that he was you know in some ways a
british asset i won't use the word agent
there are there there are some
fascinating documents that a ci
historian named thomas troy
found in which
british officers are really crowing
about the fact that they wrote the
organizing charter
for oss and you can make an argument
that having been created in this british
image in the beginning
and ci really
flowed out of oss we kept trying to act
like the brits but but that was the
basic problem that they were better at
running their kind of intelligence
service than we were
and we never learned how to create and
run our kind do you think that's fair
i think that is a fragment of the story
and that is a story that has been told
for some years
i think that
cia succeeded to the extent it did
in the first 20 25 years of its history
because it had quite a number of people
working for it who were from central
europe
who were from eastern europe
who were from russia
and who actually knew the countries that
we were interested in because they had
been born there
and they have names like polgar and
sashell and rozitsky and
they spoke many languages
they were
to steal a phrase out of context
rootless cosmopolitans
but they were but they were run by guys
with names like barnes and wisner and
you know they were run by people who
were who were not out of the ghettos of
eastern europe but out of the clubs of
manhattan
a great deal has been made
of the
skull and bones patrimony of cia
but what was
good about the early cia was by and
large
its ability to know
the target countries of central and
eastern europe and the soviet union and
a great deal of that knowledge came from
uh
ethnic
central europeans eastern europeans and
russians who worked for cia
it came from
a knowledge of the countries that we
wanted to know
tim
some of the
most famous infamous actions of the cia
were the
covert operations of the 1950s the
toppling of the mossadac regime in iran
the the coup in guatemala
talk about that period of the agency and
the extent to which you think that in a
sense um contaminated uh the
organization
send it in in a direction
uh that was inappropriate and and over
the long run harmful
the cia didn't stick up its hand and say
let's go
overthrow guatemala
in the 50s there was a great deal of
interplay
between the state department and the cia
because the gentleman who ran
them
were brothers
and
we should say john foster dulles at
state and alan dulles running the cia
and so
decisions
about what to do abroad could be made
over a cocktail
by two men whose bond
was blood
president eisenhower was not clueless
about secret operations he'd run the
greatest secret operation in american
military history
to win help in world war ii
and he believed
that
you were furious or a guinness
and if you were neutral
you were probably a guinness
john foster dulles believed that to the
marrow of his bones
and so we set out across the world
to
change governments convert people
and particularly in the middle east this
became a fascinating business
president eisenhower stressed
to the dulles brothers and to frank
wisner that we should emphasize the holy
war aspect of this that we should
support islamic jihad
against communism
and we did
probably not such a good idea in
retrospect
it was a black and white world david
it was good versus evil
and the ci was the pointy end of the
spear of american foreign policy
one uh thing that struck me because i
had never seen the declassified memos
was the the degree to which president
eisenhower
uh was suspicious and that almost
understates the degree of his of his
worriness of the agency
talk about talk about ike's uh cia
phobia if you will
oh i don't think he was phobic i think
he realized
that he wasn't getting the truth
from alan dulles
the title of legacy of ashes
comes from a very recently declassified
transcript of the last full dress
meetings of the national security
council that president eisenhower held
in the days before he left office and
handed over the presidency to john f
kennedy
and eisenhower was furious
and he said to alan dulles in front of
everyone
in his cabinet
alan
i have been after you for eight years
to organize
central intelligence and you have failed
me
i have fought an eight-year struggle
and i you have handed me a defeat
and i will hand my successor john f
kennedy a legacy of ashes
and four months later came the bay of
pigs
so let's talk about the kennedys and the
cia
this these stories uh are still the
darkest most mysterious ones in our
country's modern history i i've never
seen the story of
the intelligence links to the kennedy
assassination told with more economy and
clarity than you do in this book
so talk us through
the really extraordinary story of the
kennedy brothers obsession with cuba
after the failed coup attempt at the bay
of pigs
and just take that story if you would
through the assassination of president
kennedy
well the bay of pigs the failed invasion
of cuba of april 1961 is synonymous with
failure not just intelligence failure
but
a snafu
in which people die
and
after the bay of pigs
president kennedy just just to i mean
this the snafu as you describe it is
that people were never really honest
about what it would take to succeed it's
a haunting parallel to to iraq
one of many in your book but but people
you know at the agency never really
leveled with the policymakers that air
cover would be needed or this army would
be stranded you have one unbelievable
detail that that the maps they were
using in the bay pigs area had been made
and i think it's 1858 and they didn't
show that it was you know swampy ground
from which you couldn't escape talk
about that have you ever been to the bay
of pigs i have not i have
it is an impossible tang tangle of
mangrove and mud with these hard shell
spiny crabs scuttling all around like
it's impossible to imagine a more
nightmarish place to do a landing
the leaders of the cia and specifically
richard bissell who is the chief of the
clandestine service knew
that it was impossible
that 1500 men
could go up against a very tightly
disciplined 60 000 man army and take
over cuba and yet
they went on
it's like that old song they used to
sing about vietnam waist deep in the big
muddy and a big fool said to push on
when it was over
john kennedy was furious
and he wanted to scatter the cia to the
four winds break it up and instead he
handed
an unbelievable measure of control
over american covert operations to the
man he trusted most in the world his 35
year old brother the attorney general of
the united states robert f kennedy
bobby was
enamored
of the secret use of power
even more than his brother
but he didn't understand the first thing
about it
and he lashed richard helms who took
over the clandestine service
once helms and i were talking
over a beer
and uh helms who took over and ran the
clandestine service for five years until
he took over the ci itself
and who was then 82 years old offered to
take off his shirt and show me the scars
that he had on his back from being
horse-whipped
by robert kennedy
the kennedys
launched a new major covert action on
average every four and a half days
during the thousand days of bobby of
sorry of john kennedy's presidency and
bobby kennedy was in control
and i used that word very loosely of a
lot of them
when john kennedy installed a taping
system in the oval office
at the end of july 1962 and he switched
it on the first conversation recorded
was about overthrowing the government of
brazil
and not every day but
very close to every day was a new action
overthrow guyana great idea overthrow
haiti okay and you know the cia's
leaders and dick helms chief among them
would salute smartly and then go back to
headquarters and say
good lord how am i going to do this
do you you know thinking about the
kennedy era and the camelot aura that it
still carries
and about this uh
misuse gross misuse of of secret power
in the cia do you think there is is
something to the to the idea that the
kennedys were
uh almost uh romantic about about the
use that this idea that secret power
could change the world and make it
better in other words can can you draw a
line that connects the rhetoric
of of the kennedy administration this
you know kind of dream we have of
camelot
with the things that were going on in
the dark to try to make the world our
way
president kennedy was a great fan of the
james bond novels
by ian fleming
and he thought that's what it was like
and he promoted men at cia who were like
james bond or at least
outwardly lived like james bond
it was a fantasy of power that you could
snap your fingers and overthrow a
country
and the deepest tragedy of this
is that
he decided that it would be a good idea
to overthrow the president of south
vietnam
the country that we were desperately
trying to support in the early 1960s
against a ruthless communist enemy in
north vietnam
he set that in motion he kept the united
states one step removed
from it but he set that in motion
and there is a haunting tape
of president kennedy
three days after diem
the president of south vietnam
was assassinated
talking to himself alone in the oval
office
and ruling the day he ever set a murder
in motion
and 18 days later he was dead
richard helms said this as a final
judgment on these matters
of the united states trying to kill
castro or overthrow diem
or set assassinations in motion
and richard helms said
helms was
not
naive this man had spent his life in cia
not only is it morally reprehensible
but if you try to kill their leaders why
shouldn't they try to kill yours
well let's let's pursue that um you know
first you mentioned the killing of
jim in vietnam
fellow spy novelist charles mccary
argued charles mccary was was a ci
officer himself argued in a classic
american spy novel called the tears of
autumn that there was a link between
this assassination of gm of of a
vietnamese leader and
the assassination of president kennedy
a lot of people at the agency who knew
the secret who knew the secret that
you're going to tell us in a minute were
convinced that this was allegory and
then mccary was really talking about the
link between
the kennedy administration's efforts
through the cia to assassinate fidel
castro and the eventual assassination of
president kennedy so take us that's that
story is very well told in your book and
just walk us through the the the
remarkable story of how we tried to kill
castro and the possibility
the possibility that president kennedy
was himself murdered in some way we
still don't understand in response to
that
from the moment john kennedy was
assassinated
to the end of his own presidency
lyndon johnson was convinced
that the killing of john kennedy was
either an act of divine retribution for
the murder of tiem or blow back from the
attempt to kill fidel castro
the labyrinth that cia wandered into
after the murder of the president was
profound and dark
i'm gonna i'm gonna leave our audience
entering that dark labyrinth and we'll
return uh to our second segment and a
continued discussion of the link between
the kennedy assassination and the and
actions in cuba in a moment
afterwards and several other c-span
programs are available for download as
podcasts
more with tim weiner and david ignatius
in just a moment
hi i'm janelle henry part of the
political team here at c-span my job
this year covering the presidential race
is really exciting we'll be
crisscrossing the nation to bring you
the very latest in political activities
campaign announcements candidate
speeches and fundraisers we'll give you
an up close look at how the candidates
interact with the public as they seek
support for their party nominations the
kind of unscripted moments you won't
find anywhere else and we won't just
stop at the battleground states we'll
follow the race wherever it goes for
more information check out our website
at campaignnetwork.org and click on our
video archive section for past programs
and political news
the cspan networks
providing you access to public affairs
on television
radio
and on the web
[Music]
book tv invites you to visit our new
enhanced website www.booktv.org
recently redesigned we've added more
information a new look and made it even
easier for you to use
stop by booktv.org for more about book
fairs book tv news and bus events or
check out the full weekend schedule for
a new schedule printing feature or to
watch video online
let us know what you think send emails
to online at cspan.org
afterwards with tim weiner and david
ignatius continues
we're back with tim weiner who's the
author of a remarkable new history of
the cia called
legacy of ashes
and we are going to continue our
conversation where we left it off we
were entering tim this dark and
mysterious question
of the kennedy assassination and the
cia's efforts to kill fidel castro tell
us a little bit about that story and
then about what happened afterward
the roots of this story lie at the end
of the eisenhower presidency
when
ci was authorized
although there's nothing on paper
to
[Music]
get rid of castro in a political sense
not to kill him
after the bay of pigs in the spring of
1961
the stakes went up
and though again there is nothing on
paper
there's no question that bobby kennedy
oversaw
more than one
mission
to kill fidel castro to murder him
the cia which has a military ethos
believed it was acting under a lawful
order
from the commander-in-chief
and saluted smartly
and then sort of buried its face in its
hands and said oh lord
now what
the chemists came up with poison pills
they never got there
the mafia was enlisted
to get the poison pills or to put a thug
next to castro and blow his head off
nothing worked
and finally in the last days of
president kennedy's life
dashing
desmond fitzgerald
the man most liked james bond in the cia
he drove a jaguar
he lived in a beautiful house in
georgetown
made a contact of face-to-face contact
with a cuban major who did not like
fidel castro at all
and they talked
about murder weapons
rifles
telescopic sites
silencers
and they were meeting they were
i think your book says he was there on
behalf of robert kennedy is that right
he said he was sent as an emissary of
bobby kennedy which was dangerously
close to the truth if not the whole
truth itself
and and and shortly thereafter
president kennedy is is killed in dallas
by lee harvey oswald a man who we know
had defected the soviet union but
arguably more important had had been
uh at the soviet embassy in mexico city
seeking to go to cuba
who'd had all sorts of involvement with
cuba issues
in your own mind
tim
what is your judgment about whether
there is in fact a link between the ci's
efforts to kill castro which are clear
and documented
uh and the murder of jfk
there's no evidence to connect the cia
to the murder of an american president
and the thought is so abhorrent
that it's difficult to even speak
but
lyndon johnson believed that there was a
direct connection
that
kennedy was trying to kill castro but
castro got to him first that's i i
didn't mean to suggest that that that
the cia killed kennedy which i think is
preposterous but that but that but that
castro you know knowing that we were
going after him decided to go after our
president do you well you know in a
scale of zero to a hundred what what
level of credence would you give that
what's crucial is that in the minutes
and hours and days and weeks after the
assassination of president kennedy the
cia
had a mountain of leads
pieces of circumstantial evidence
that very strongly suggested
that lee harvey oswald was a cuban agent
or a soviet agent
and it really the question admits only
two proofs
either
the communists
tried to kill kennedy or they didn't and
either
lee harvey oswald got off a million one
shot with a mail-order rifle
or he didn't and richard helms
who had to pursue this question
from november 1963
for the next decade
said the question would always be an
open book
and in in your mind um you're the
historian what's your judgment i keep
trying to
get you to declare on this my judgment
is that
the absence of evidence
is not
evidence of absence
but
that there is absolutely no strong proof
that takes you down the road
that
the soviets or the cubans killed kennedy
when the soviet and cuban files
are opened if they are ever opened we
will know
i
i'll
mention one brief
anecdote that sticks in my mind on this
on this subject like you tim
i talked fairly often with richard helms
who had been director of the cia
and in the late 1980s i was the editor
of the washington post's opinion section
called outlook
and in that capacity i commissioned an
article that discussed
in part for the first time
the remarkable link in time between dez
fitzgerald's meetings in paris with the
cuban agent i think his name was rubella
and and the subsequent kennedy
assassination and i got a phone call
after was published from helms
and he was furious
and he thought he would you know was a
very unusual this was one of the most
calm and reasoned
men i ever was a gentleman's gentleman
and a remarkable man
and one of the heroes of this book i i
think but i want to talk about that in a
minute but here he was on the phone and
he was really upset that we had
published this and i i will i will
always think
that dick helms had this awful annoying
fear
that
it was conceivable remote but
conceivable that there was a connection
and he didn't like to see
that connection explored in print as we
did this in this outlook article what
did you you talked often with dick helms
did you have that same feeling that he
this ate at him a little bit
i think the uncertainty over whether
there was a soviet conspiracy to kill
kennedy or a cuban conspiracy ate at him
mightily
when you come to understand a little bit
about
men like dick helms
men like frank wisner
men like dez fitzgerald
who were
the
best and the brightest of cia
from the late 40s onwards
the killing tension
of their lives
is unbearable
frank wisner died by his own hand at 56.
dez fitzgerald dropped dead of a heart
attack at
what killed them was the cold war
and the tension
of prosecuting it
talk about dick helms i said a moment
ago that i thought he was in some ways a
hero of this book in part because he
wasn't swept away he was a you know a
kind of classic
establishment figure
hair not out of place always perfectly
dressed but there was a way in which he
had the intelligence
collection instincts of an fbi man in
fact you know helms tended to lean in
the agency as you know there was the
kind of you know preppy camp and there
was the ex-fbi guy camp and helms
interestingly often lean with the ex-fbi
guys and i i'm wondering whether you
know in the in this story
you have many people who really didn't
get the job done you're pretty you're
pretty honest and tough in your
judgments about them but turning the
pages i felt that you that you basically
had a fondness for helms
and i'll tell you why apart from
whatever personal feelings i had about
being in the presence of
a man
40 years older than i who had lived
through
uh
every
turn of the road of the cold war
what dick helms stood for was espionage
getting the information
you'll remember that dick helms was also
once a newspaper man a wire service
reporter
what people like wisner
and people like dez fitzgerald and i
should add people like bill casey who
was first ronald reagan's campaign
manager and then his cia director stood
for was the quick fix silver bullets
covert action without intelligence is a
fool's errand
and we have gone on that errand
time and again
and what dick helm stood for was
intelligence
and if there is an argument in this book
it is an action without knowledge
is fatal
dick helm stood for knowledge
dick helms also
was a man like every cia director who
faced an awful lot of pressure from
presidents and he faced pressure in
particular
in the
years really surrounding watergate in
which president nixon who was a
conspiratorial
talk about a man who
loved covert action
who who wanted to use the ci misused the
cia and it's argued really tried to lay
off the watergate scandal on the cia he
did how well do you think dick helms
resisted that pressure
he fought it tooth and nail
up to the point where he believed he had
received a lawful order
from the president
there was an excruciating 16 days
after the watergate break-in
where the president
is clearly
obstructing justice
for which he was
driven from office that particular crime
trying to use a specious argument of
national security to get the cia to call
off the fbi
which was investigating a federal crime
of wiretapping
at the democratic national committee
headquarters here in washington
that crime had been committed by
six ci veterans two
veteran officers and four veteran cuban
agents
and so nixon in his mind said well maybe
i can make this argument plausibly these
are all xcia guys
for 16 days
helms wavered
had he fallen
the cia would have been destroyed along
with richard nixon
but in the end he pulled himself up and
he said no to the president of the
united states
a word for which he was cashiered
some months later
we then move into the to the period that
we've been reminded of in the last week
with the public release of the so-called
family jewels
the unspeakable
crimes the cia
unspeakable never to be revealed and
here they are you can go to the to the
web website cia website and look at them
now
talk about about that period of
revelation of ci misdeeds
by the church committee in the senate
and by the house intelligence committee
you know there's an argument that some
partisans of the cia make that
that
so weakened so knocked the cia off
balance
made it so difficult
for the ci to be reconstituted as an
effective secret intelligence agency
that has never really
come back
i suspect you don't buy that argument
but explain why
the so-called crimes of the cia with
very few exceptions
were the fault of presidents
do you think the cia stuck up its hand
and said gee would be a great idea to
kill fidel castro no it did not
presidents
order the cia to do what it does
and the cia takes the fall
the only lasting crime the only crime of
consequence
that the cia has committed
is to fail to keep presidents fully
informed about what's going on in the
world
well that certainly is a theme that
resonates as we as we as we think about
iraq let's um you know continue with
with with this with this story
sometimes
reading
your book and seeing all the you know
mistakes both in presidential direction
and sometimes in execution
of policy by by the agency you wonder
how did we ever win the cold war um give
us your your sense of that i mean talk a
little bit um you say that you know
ci likes to claim it its successes are
secret and its failures are trumpeted
and you say at one point it has it has
precious few successes but at the end of
the day we did win the cold war and and
and tell us what what role you think the
cia played in that extraordinary result
in the end
the cia spent
a great part of the first 15 years of
its existence from the late 40s to the
early 60s
flinging foreign agents
over the iron curtain
uh with parachutes flinging them over
the bamboo curtain of red china flinging
them into north korea hammering
to no
and whatsoever except the deaths of
thousands of foreign agents
at an attempt to understand what was
going on in these secretive
police states
that were our enemies our mortal enemies
at the end of that
in the early 1960s the cia helped create
spy satellites
satellites that
are 22 000 miles above the earth and
look down
and can count
armies
tanks
missiles and that
helped keep the cold war cold
the soviet union was not that hard at
target it turned out because the soviet
union was like a mountain
it was
the power structure was like a triangle
with one man on top and then two and
four and six and eight twelve and until
he got to several million
and it was static it didn't move
the soviet union
whereas the enemy today is flat and it
moves like a river and we can't
see the currents underneath
from space
the cia
was steadfast
in
contributing to arms control
by
accounting for
the power of the soviet military and
especially its nuclear forces
the cia never had a great spy inside the
kremlin
even the you know pankowski
is is cited oleg pankowski has cited
that was been called the spy who saved
the world because he provided timely
intelligence before the cuban missile
crisis do you think that's hype you know
who saved the world during the cuban
missile crisis it was john mccone
john mcconne was the director of central
intelligence at kennedy hired after he
fired alan dulles
and an amazing man really
a fiery anti-communist a conservative
republican from california a man who'd
made a fortune building ships
uh
during after during and after world war
ii
john mcconne alone
in the american government
said the soviets are going to put
nuclear missiles into cuba
and he's walked alone in his councils no
one believed him the cia as an
institution rejected
the idea and the kennedy white house
said that's preposterous
finally mccone argued you've got to put
a u2 up there
and they did and by god
the soviets were putting missiles into
cuba if john mcconne had not done that
it would have been a fatal complete it
would have been a done deal
and we would have faced a nuclear
standoff beyond our imagination
i am old enough to remember not simply
watching on television as
president kennedy displayed those u2
photographs of the suspected
sites missile sites in cuba but to
remember before the display of those
photographs my father who was working at
the pentagon as a civilian
being unusually skittish i mean in a way
that you know kids kids can read their
parents
and you knew something was up and he was
staying at the office sometimes almost
all night that was in the period when
they were thinking of invading cuba and
they were assembling
the army that would do it
but
again when we think about this the story
of the cold war this long battle that
defined the careers of dick helms and so
many at the ci do you think that they
should take a kind of credit for that
victory or do you think in the end this
soviet union was just a big overripe
thing that just fell of its own accord
it wasn't it wasn't the cia pushing it
would fell of its own accord
soviet communism was a rotten
system
and
i think there's little evidence
some but not much
to support the idea that
we won the cold war because we spent a
trillion dollars more on weaponry
or because we knew that we had picked
the kremlin's pocket and we knew their
next move
the people who were running the soviet
union by the late 1980s were
old
vain
foolish men who believed their own
propaganda
and that
is why the soviet union fell
i would amend that only as follows the
the group that came in at the end
starting with yuri and dropoff
knew how bad it was yuri and dropoff had
been head of the kgb and the kgb didn't
know the truth they knew that the soviet
union was desperately behind did they
tell the public bureau well you know the
reason the soviet union began to change
sharply and and suddenly uh in in the
80s
was i think a kind of internal coup by
the kgb initially led by on drop off i i
was going to moscow in that period for
the wall street journal
and later led by on drop-offs man
gorbachev you know who was desperate to
reform
soviet communism thought it was possible
and of course we now know every move he
made to reform it to open it up through
glasnost just made the job of
dismantling it easier but i i do think
that had it not been these kgb sort of
internal reformers if that's the right
word
um i don't want to say that the soviet
system would still be intact today but
it would have been a heck of a lot
harder to to have the end game it was a
rotten system and we're well shut of it
i think on that there would there would
certainly be agreement i want to get to
to iraq which as i said the earlier
looms over this book as as the kind of
tragic finale of the story and in a
sense is the prism through which our
generation
will see the ci but but before i get to
iraq i want to ask you
a question that kept
recurring in my mind as i read legacy of
ashes and that is
what do you think we still don't know
you know a lot
you know you've spent years now
researching the subject and you've
written what appears to be a quite
comprehensive history but you're in a
better position than most
to say what you think we don't know and
so talk about that
well there are as don rumsfeld used to
say known unknowns and unknown unknowns
and i can't tell you about the latter
we know
why
our intelligence system
failed in producing
a considered judgment that saddam
hussein had
an arsenal bristling with chemical and
biological weapons
and that
this justified
in effect a preemptive war
against iraq
in 2002 and 2003 that failure was
because the freshest intelligence the
cia had was four or five years old
what we don't know
and what we may never know
is
the interactions between
cia the white house
and state
in the preceding year
um
the president of the united states
george w bush
turned the powers of american
intelligence on in ways that they hadn't
been turned on for 30 or 40 years
training them inside the borders of the
united states and also pushing the cia
to serve as kind of a paramilitary
police
abducting people
assassinating people
throwing them in
prisons
that is a misuse of the cia that is not
what the cia was created to do and in
order to do it
they've had to second uh you know
special operations commandos from the
american military
it's extraordinary
that
this president
and his relationship with the cia
who
after all have renamed their
headquarters the george bush center for
intelligence after the president's
father
um
has been so strained
in 2004 the president was asked a
question in public
so what did the cia tell you that about
what life would be like in iraq
post-saddam
and the president said
well they said it could be bad they said
it could be good they said it could be
all right they were just guessing
now just guessing is not intelligence
well now
tim you know on that question um i i
wonder if the ci doesn't deserve a
little bit more
credit as i read this
story they they did warn with some
specificity before the invasion about
the danger
of ethnic conflict and through
2003 and 2004 when the white house was
insisting everything was going great
they uh chief cessation sent
increasingly sharp
warnings and the president said what is
this guy some kind of a defeatist
exactly they were they were they were
prepared to to to reject the the
warnings so
aren't we being a little harsh and
saying these were just this was the gang
that couldn't shoot straight and didn't
know anything
donald rumsfeld secretary of defense for
the first six years
of this administration and dick cheney
vice president
had been dealing with cia
for quite a number of years going back
to the nixon and ford administrations
they were to put a politely skeptics
about the cia's ability to know the
world
during the first gulf war in 1991
the ci discovered that sanam did indeed
have an underground program to build
nuclear
weapons but they discovered it long
after the war was over and dick cheney
who was secretary of defense at that
point said
you know we blew up everything
that we knew about in iraq during the
gulf war and we didn't know about this i
will never trust the cia again and he
never has
and that has been hugely influential on
the president
whose father after all
was one of the greatest supporters the
cia has ever had
it is not
an american or unpatriotic to say we
have to do better look
the cia's i.t it's information
technology is terrible and that's by the
ci's own internal reports
fifty percent
of the people of the workforce at cia
today
are new they have less than five years
experience
and by the cia's own standard they're
not good to go overseas they're not
ready they're trainees
we as a nation have to do better at this
so let's in concluding
tim let's talk a little bit about what
the intelligence service that america
needs
might look like
and you know
based on your
reading of this of this history that's
told in legacy of ashes what do you know
that other people ought to about how
that
intelligence service might be
reconstituted
the only superpower in the world doesn't
have enough interest
in what's going on in the world to run
an espionage service and kind of threw
up his hands in despair
that was 10 years ago and things haven't
improved very much
if we want to get good at this and i
think the national survival of the
united states might depend on it because
we are in an intelligence war that may
last as long as the cold war
then we need to begin
a program
as urgent and as important
as putting a man on the moon was in the
60s
and teach high school students and
college students how to speak arabic and
chinese
and farsi
and korean
so that we can begin to know our enemy
with that hope for the future uh i want
to thank our author tim weiner author of
legacy of ashes an extraordinary look at
cia and for his thoughts about where we
where we go how we rebuild thank you
[Music]